-That's a crowd right there!
-Come on!
-Waking everyone up! Wake up!
And welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
I appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, today the
White House announced a new way
that they're trying to get
more Americans vaccinated.
Listen to this.
-Some of America's biggest
dating apps are joining
the White House push
to get Americans vaccinated.
Apps including Tinder, Hinge
and Bumble will offer badges
for singles to display
their vaccination status.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sure.
That's great.
The only other shot dating apps
ever promoted was Penicillin,
so I think that's a great --
[ Laughter ]
I like the idea.
You get your shots,
you meet someone on Tinder,
then get a few more shots.
[ Laughter ]
Usually when you hear
"White House" and "Tinder"
in the same sentence,
it's followed by
"resignation" and "disgrace."
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
You know this started when
some CDC employee was like,
"Uh, honey, it's not what you
think. It's a work project."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, they're offering
a bunch of features for users
who get the vaccine,
like being able to add
an "I'm vaccinated" badge
to their profile.
[ Laughter ]
Americans are like,
"Ooh, that's even hotter
than being verified on Twitter."
[ Laughter ]
"That's hot."
N-B.
[ Laughter ]
That's my new jam.
-Oh, cool.
-N-B?
-N-B, yeah.
-No biggie?
-Yeah, you don't say D anymore.
-You don't say N-B-D?
You just go N-B?
-No, "no big deal" -- too long.
-Right.
-N-B-D. N-B-D. Fine.
N-B.
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
Check, please.
-That's sharp, yeah.
-Right?
-I feel hipper.
-That's...
That's hot.
[ Laughter ]
N-B.
The dating sites are also adding
a lot of other helpful badges
too, like "actually six feet
tall."
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That'll work.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
Prove it!
Stand next to something.
Stand next to something
that's six feet tall. Yeah.
-It's a giant fire hydrant.
[ Laughter ]
-Also they have the badge,
"This is a recent photo."
Yeah, yeah. I want to know.
Yeah, I want to know,
is this a recent photo?
Then there's also the badge, of
course, "Not a serial killer."
And that's good
if you know that.
Also for the weirdos
who post group photos
on their dating profile,
they offer,
"I'm the second one
from the right."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I know.
I know it's a group photo,
but it's a good one of me,
so I'm going to post it.
I mean, look who else you could
have been stuck with.
My other friends are disasters."
Speaking of vaccinations, I saw
that people will soon be able
to get their vaccine shots
at airports like LaGuardia.
[ Audience ohs ]
New Yorkers heard and were like,
"I'm flying through LaGuardia.
You think I care about living?"
[ Laughter ]
"I just ate a cold hot dog
and flat soda."
[ Laughter ]
"I don't care."
I'm guessing the people who are
waiting to get vaccinated
at the airport
are the same people
buying luggage at the airport.
How busy are you?
[ Laughter ]
"I'm just gonna wear
10 layers of clothes
and get through security,
then I'll peel off each layer
and fold in it my new luggage."
[ Laughter ]
Get this. I saw that
the Pope just signed off on
the first all-electric
Popemobile.
Check this thing out.
Look at this.
Huh?
[ Laughter ]
Let me see that again.
That spaceship-looking thing?
Ladies and gentlemen, here he is
coming down the procession,
Pope Tron Paul.
There he is.
[ Laughter ]
It looks like the Pope's
going to exit that thing
smoking a vape pen, doesn't it?
[ Laughter ]
Right? Yeah, he comes out --
♪♪
♪ Summer loving had me ♪
Wait, why is he doing
John Travolta?
[ Laughter ]
Why is he -- What is he doing?
In the new "Grease"?
-The Pope is in
the new "Grease"?
-The Pope is --
They redid "Grease."
-The Pope?
-The Pope is now Danny Zuko.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-And he's not smoking cigarettes
'cause that's bad for you.
-Vaping.
-So he vapes. That's correct.
-That's hot.
[ Laughter ]
N-B.
Can I see that once again
really quick?
I just want to see that vehicle,
yeah.
It looks like the new Domino's
delivery car, doesn't it?
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, could I get
a blessed crust pizza? Thanks.
Sorry! Oh.
I'm sorry, Pope. I apologize."
[ Laughter ]
Some business news --
this summer, Google is opening
its first ever retail store.
[ Audience oohs ]
Yeah.
And since it's Google,
you just walk in,
they already know what
you're looking for.
[ Laughter ]
"How you doing, Dave?
Yeah, we have your phone.
Also, unicorns aren't real."
So hey, welcome."
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news -- I got
really excited when I saw this.
Sarah Jessica Parker,
Bette Midler and Kathy Najimy
are coming back to do
a sequel of "Hocus Pocus."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
I love the original.
So do my kids. My kids love it.
Tariq, what's a classic movie
that you and your kids love?
-I don't know, Jimmy.
You tell me.
[ Laughter ]
-That would be ridiculous,
Tariq, 'cause I'm asking you.
-Wow!
So now I'm ridiculous.
-What's going on?
Are we in a fight?
-Clearly.
-But I don't even know
what we're fighting about.
-Clearly!
Okay, earlier in the week,
you asked me
what was the scariest movie
I've ever seen.
I said "Signs."
And you made fun of me.
-Come on, Tariq.
I mean, that was just --
-No, no, no, no, no!
You don't get to dismiss this.
It's time for
"Tariq Proves His Case."
♪ -Tariq proves his case ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Signs" is a scary movie.
It has very effective jump
scares, a foreboding soundtrack,
and the scariest thing of all --
Joaquin Phoenix
committing to a role.
[ Laughter ]
"Signs" is scary.
This has been
"Tariq Proves His Case."
♪ -Tariq proves his case ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, if you get to prove your
case, then I get to prove mine.
It's time for
"Jimmy Proves His Case."
♪ -Jimmy proves his case ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Signs" isn't scary.
It's not even a horror movie.
it's sci-fi.
Also, the CGI hasn't aged well,
and Joaquin Phoenix
isn't scary in the movie.
He's endearing.
This has been
"Jimmy Proves His Case."
♪ -Jimmy proves his case ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are we good now?
-Man, shut up!
[ Laughter ]
It's time for
"Tariq Proves His Case"!
♪ -Tariq proves his case ♪
-You asked me my opinion,
and I gave you my opinion.
[ Laughter ]
Opinions are
inherently subjective.
Therefore, it's correct.
[ Laughter ]
This has been
"Tariq Proves His Case."
♪ -Tariq proves his case ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-It's time for
"Jimmy Proves His Case."
♪ -Jimmy proves his case ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Tariq, you say opinions are
subjective, and you're right.
I'm sorry for jeopardizing
our friendship!
-You know what?
I'm sorry too!
Look, I was hurt
and I overreacted!
-You're a great friend
and I don't want anything
to come between us!
-Agreed!
Scary thinking I could
ever lose you as a friend.
-Yeah.
But not as scary as "Signs"!
♪ -You're the best around ♪
♪ Nothing's gonna ever ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?
-I have no idea.
-Then you froze at the end?
-I couldn't even --
-Yeah. What is that about?
-I could've held that freeze.
It looked like a glitch.
I could've easily just froze.
♪ -You're the best around ♪
♪ Nothing's gonna ever ♪
-That's longer than the bit.
-Yeah, like "Police Academy."
-Yeah.
I thought they were gonna freeze
it. That's why I broke --
[ Laughter ]
-Looked like you were boxing.
-Go sit down.
-Thought you were boxing.
Play cards.
Have a round of pinochle.
-Oh, I love pinochle.
-Oh, I do too.
[ Laughter ]
-And finally, I read about
a Japanese bullet train driver
who took a three-minute
bathroom break
while the train was
going 90 miles an hour.
When they heard no one
was driving the train,
passengers took a bathroom break
right in their seats.